here's a pretty good story though
Babbitt called me one day uh and he said
hey you have to go to the hospital right
now they're going to need to amputate
Mitch's leg you have to go there and
talk him into letting them amputees leg
or he'll die of gangrene yes that is a
really fantastic story you will hear in
this podcast I tease it up front and
it's a story that I probably wanted to
hear my ever since I heard it happening
but you know comics are pretty uh but
why did he have to do I kiss a bull you
gotta listen to the podcast babe it's a
good story you never knew about that you
never knew that about yeah did they
actually cut his leg off no no he got a
second opinion and they kept his leg oh
my god Fairbanks is a guy that was like
I really think you should cut it off
because and don't worry it's you here
you gotta listen to podcast is a
fantastic podcast I've known Chris
Fairbanks for a long time and I really
do truthfully enjoy Chris Fairbanks he
is one of the fun he's like a true comic
spirit like he just wants to have a good
time in giggle he's got a great eye her
just heard him recently on Stan House
podcast talking about having a bad set
he's just the best you've known
Fairbanks for a long time - yeah he
tells a really great story about getting
drugged by a gay dude oh my god yeah
holy cow a really great pod really good
one smooth no sponsors today that's
right guys we're going to keep this
super short tour dates where's my
[ __ ] phone do you have anything to
plug Lee in no by a machine shirt by
Machine shirt tour dates
uh I'm in stand-up Huntsville on the
20th this is a Thursday I'm assuming
that shows sold out but I don't know
Wild West Comedy Wild West Comedy
Festival I'm at Zanies
Friday and Saturday night Friday
afternoon we're doing a call in sick to
work live podcast we
me Nate bargatze and Sean Patton Yuk
Yuk's the next week
Detroit crowfoot Ballroom the fourth
Cincinnati funnybone the 5th and 6th of
May and then crapshoot comedy festival
in Vegas on the 19th followed by Bisbee
live podcast with Doug Stanhope on the
20th and that's kind of it I know that
we're doing the Blue Note in Hawaii on
the 31st of May in Honolulu and then
Cobbs comedy club Sacramento the
following week the 9th 10th and 11th
Kansas City improv the u.s. opens that
week I might do a live podcast while I
watch the US Open in my hotel room
Orlando improv the following week then
Legion of skanks festival the 25th in
New York I'm throwing a post party on
the 25th Lynch come out to New York for
the Legion skank festival maybe Cherokee
Casino Columbus funnybone Pittsburgh
Improv hilarities Cleveland the 27th
28th 29th I think we are probably
shooting my sitcom in August that's what
we've been talking about I have big news
with other things I got a video I'm
going to be releasing for Mother's Day
that we're in the process of editing
that Leeanne is not a fan of and let's
just let's keep it tight and start the
podcast that sound good Leeanne sounds
good
anything you want to talk about no
nothing at all nothing at all
my ed that's an entire podcast is it
maybe we should do a Star Trek podcast I
should we should we should yeah and
break down how I would handle situations
based on my Kirk isms yes exactly and
you Spock the [ __ ] out of things Spock
and you might be interesting yeah maybe
all right guys so today's podcast is a
[ __ ] burner you're going to love it
and thank you everyone for listened to
the Gaad free one I have a backlog a
bunch of podcast because I'm touring
really hard so I've done a bunch that
I've talked about and you'll hear me
talk about on this podcast and just know
that they will be coming out soon I also
I'm going to be releasing my podcast I
did with um Todd glass
my buddy Chris Martin I was just with
him in uh in Utah this past week he's a
British comic I did his podcast over in
London and he's now moved here with his
wife Hannah and he's got a new podcast
that I listen to and it's really [ __ ]
funny it's really I really enjoyed it he
just started it it's called babysitting
Trevor with Carl Donnelly and Chris
Martin you can get it on iTunes that's
the title babysitting Trevor with Carl
Donnelly and Chris Martin they basically
hang out with this older crazy British
comic or Australian comic who's had
insane life experiences and just shares
them and it's a great podcast so go
check it out the reason I was going to
say that is because I'm also going to re
releasing my podcast I did with Todd
glass on my RSS feed but you can go get
it right now it's a two-parter it's
[ __ ] great and I'm going to release
it so that you just have it in your in
your queue and then you're going to love
it and then you can go download all of
Todd Glass's
I really will say Todd glass might have
the most invented podcast the other out
of any of us and you can go to all these
into the laughable comm and download all
these podcasts so funny laughable 'he's
got this new thing now where you can
follow comics and they don't even have
to have a podcast you can just follow
comics you like and then hear them all
all your favorite podcast and get their
tour dates laughable is [ __ ] killing
it if you're not hearing me talk about
it you're hearing Greg Fitzsimmons
talking about it
Tony Hinchcliffe the Ari Shaffir is
coming back I think I'm going to see him
this week that's it there's going to be
a long read check out laughable
check out babysitting Trevor with Chris
and Karl and in Todd glass and tour
dates I guess this was a long promo that
said let's get into this [ __ ] podcast
you're going to love it ladies and
gentlemen stand-up comedian Chris
Fairbanks
[Music]
that's one test to zoom three six and up
we're both on not in driving through the
room six channels that's what the six
stands for are there six channels the
two on top of Mike on top is - oh yeah I
got that but I don't I don't look at it
that way I'm good it's four channels
whoo that's for Mike right well so
interesting mine I enjoy the ambient car
driving noise what's your podcast you're
talking the villian we request one test
- wait what's your podcast it was do you
need a ride
I think people to the airport yeah we
haven't been doing it really Karen has a
very popular murder Karen kill Gareth
yeah I just texted back and forth with
her in Georgia I have a really funny
story about them I'm getting on I'm
gonna try to get him on my podcast next
week okay um okay great I knew Georgia
for a long time without her knowing who
I am but we did a we both worked at
Travel Channel or the kind of she had
like a web series I think with them
you've been there for a decade of seven
years it's a very I talked about it in
therapy today
yeah they abused you I'm not working for
them right now
because I kept swinging you off the
sides of roller coasters I know that's
me that that blame goes to me directly
because because I have a horrible sense
for validation yeah um me too I want
everyone to like me
including carnies and dude it's so bad
but that sense of validation comes
around and starts creeping into one of
the videos one a couple of videos that
uh that I fought so hard to get them to
put online just recently got put online
like when the show is airing I was like
can we put some stuff in and it just
recently started airing and one went
viral got eighty million views and he's
a million that is perspective wise
that's when news channels start talking
about you like eighty million is an
aggressive amount of views and it really
is the poor
where you drop your kids off at school
and every other parent says they just
saw your video right like 25 I have a
video that has 25 million views and that
sells tickets 80 million views gets
people I'll tell you what 80 million
views does it raises every single view
on travel channels network by five
million views oh wow and so my sense of
validation is you know I'm very
comfortable with where Travel Channel
and I are right now I like doing
stand-up I think I think for a long time
I was biting my tongue and not saying
the things I wanted to say on stage or
nothing bad but I just was always very
mindful and right now that's not the
case and I'm doing well and stand-up and
so part of me is like so I came in if
yet I didn't want to ride rollercoasters
I didn't want to jump off buildings I
did I like I just was past that I'm
having a meeting with the new president
going I don't wanna I don't I wonder
about roller coasters before so that's
about that oh wait yeah yeah yeah and I
had to come to terms of like what I
wanted I loved trip flip but I didn't I
didn't it's like sometimes you'd get
travelers who weren't that awesome
to be on camera yeah yeah and but there
was no way you could be like less of
them more of me like I want to do a show
about me I want me to be the focus but I
won't have to ride a roller coaster did
you ever say hey can you turn the
cameras off for a minute could you guys
be more awesome oh dude we had such bad
experiences on trip flip you have no
[ __ ] oh yeah I mean like colossal bad
like brought an interracial couple to a
Civil War Reenactment and then that
night had them sleep in old slaves
quarters we're walking the owner of the
plantations wife because she caught the
interracial couple and murdered them
there's now that's a scooby-doo that I
saw early got this poor kid was out of
Alaska and I'd played in UV gossin I
played in legitimately on it or they the
guy that owns it was pretending on it
nope with a projector
it was so haunted that the part of the
sketch we had them do was we gave them a
bunch of haunting equipment
and they had to see if they found a
Spectre at night like it was I mean we
that was such a [ __ ] I mean the show
itself behind the scenes was so [ __ ]
funny in the show itself was enjoyable
and I think it taught you got a lot of
take away from it but I don't know so
that's not why I brought you here to
talk about my Travel Channel therapy I
just I was I was very am very curious
about it though but I don't you we're
talking about Karen kill Gareth yeah she
now talk about thrill seeker now I'm
just gonna no but so my only interesting
little story I'm sure I showed us with
them so you'll hear this twice now
they'll never hear they'll hear it once
because they'll just because I'll tell
it to them Olympic they listen to my
podcast I became a fan of the podcast
because it was new it's on the top of
charts so I go and murdered stuff I mean
I watched forensic tiles every everyone
is infatuated with death but I like the
way they tell it to each other
I love the like the light heartedness or
the seriousness of the gravitas will
bring to it so I reach out to I said
something I just said I like the podcast
and a lot of people might a lot of my
fans started being like hey you know
Berlin and Brian Bollinger who's it you
know I remember that guy yes delineate
that's he still does he's producing re
show and a lot of assignment in New York
and so maybe it does of in New York
right now I don't know I saw him the
other night
um he's nice he sent me an email and I
was getting on stage so I didn't get a
chance to read the whole thing you know
he just spot a few words
and he's like murder Georgia tomorrow
and and I was like and my daughter's
name is Georgia and immediately I was
like what the [ __ ] and my heart sank and
I was like it's a threat from somebody
and I [ __ ] just I'm scrolling to my
phone trying to get to it
and then I see Georgia Karen my favorite
murder and I was like oh my god you dick
yeah you didn't know my daughter's name
was Georgia oh that's the best but you
and Karen used to do we we're going to
keep doing there's been a lot of mostly
people on Twitter that want to hear the
dozens of people have been missing it so
we're going to do it like once a month I
think but for a while I thought we would
end up killing someone because
it's hard to operate that zoom six like
we're recording on right now and drive
and think of things to say especially
when you're pulling into LAX and I would
be drenched with sweat I wasn't enjoying
route the process yeah I was I enjoy I
enjoyed this podcast I'm grabbing my
head oh when you're sitting in a safe
room it's the most stimulating where
this podcast a great deal um I'm I'm
grateful for it because for the most
part I don't know if I'd hang out with
anybody if I didn't do it
oh really yeah like I don't know if I'd
have any real I'm just making sure
there's no humming I had a podcast that
I did with two guys well when are you
going to hang out I mean that night you
do show so that's usually when people
hang out there's sort of a hang out
element to do and stand-up there's a
hang out but my problem right now with
my hangout is that it turns in like last
night I was supposed to go to the
premiere or something and hang out with
a bunch of comics I didn't go to Michael
being healthy don't go who gives a [ __ ]
how many my ears you not go to and then
you're just going to end up getting
[ __ ] up yet I and then coming home and
then not working out then and then
Fairbanks will come over and you'll tax
him you'll be like hey can we do 12 oh
yeah yeah and so I was like instead I
got up at 4:00 I wrote a joke I you
didn't go out last night cuz of me
those are you that's all I'm Aaron I
always look for where I am in the
conversation long list like sometimes if
someone tells me hey they mention you a
podcast it's the best podcast I've ever
listened to it was the best thing ever
when you mentioned that cocktail thing
on Jim Norton or what uh nope Ian you
know Peter was hoping in doing the a a
yeah oh it's to do it first of all but
can I tell you what bums me out about to
this business more people don't [ __ ]
do that like I saw it and I couldn't
stop thinking about it for those of you
don't know can you just tell them what
it is uh well that we did first ate it
with an old dragnet episode I don't know
if you've seen that one act I didn't
like that one yeah I like that one even
more but we basically take an old movie
in this case it was cocktail and
composite me in Forrest Gump me and two
scenes in the movie kind of rieta that
change those
rayline but we literally were moving Tom
Cruise to the side and having me be in
his place for Brian Brown's eyeline you
know like I was a third character added
to this two character and then you
change this ridiculous movie about two
guys trying to be famous bartenders
which the 80s are so ridiculous one
everyone in high school is 40 and then
just story like the movies like that and
set to a reggae soundtrack but wait but
what yeah and then he ends up in off so
in this I just I end up murdering
everyone because everyone likes murder
right dude it is so how hard was not to
shoot it was if it's me in front of a
piece of green construction but never be
editing poly hard there is yeah I didn't
have anything to do with that Mike
Upchurch who's an old mr. show writer
and everything but that I met the CIA
yet another guy right yeah we at
Stanhope sang drunk he was he was
sitting next to us but he yeah I died on
him oh I know how much he would have it
done fast but I think he stays up late
really had just keying people out on not
a new computer with not new software
which gives it a look like the it gets a
laugh when I'm suddenly sliding across
and that's kind of yeah pixelated rather
than if it looked really clean and it
looked like i was really in there i
think that's part of the this is a you
guys we wander some guys i geeked out
over in a while oh yeah yeah but I saw
you and I and I would say that out of
all of us that worked on reality bites
back my I mean I just told a story about
you yesterday uh to Chris Martin not the
guy from wasn't about how good my diet
was no oh my god Chris Martin from the
UK that has moved here yeah he's great
like oh you know yep
okay yeah we were talking about you and
he said I said the thing I like about
the thing I like about comics I don't
like I'm not a big fan of like I won't
name names but like the comics that are
as a feeling I'm about to agree with you
like the the
I don't know it's the students of comedy
that work really hard and they and they
you know you their act reeks of hard
work as opposed to talent or as opposed
to natural ability when I said the thing
I like about a comic like the thing I
love about Dave Chappelle is I feel like
if you sat out if you sat next to him at
a wedding and you'd never met him you'd
be laughing your dick off yeah yeah if
he wasn't famous right it was just a
felony never gotten famous at a wedding
Hugh be if you were sitting with him in
college and he was your suite mate and
you guys were watching TV for the first
time you'd be howling your [ __ ] ass
off suite mate this is that you think
going if you go to Australia let's just
say you meet a dude and he's your suite
mate so I know what you're and there are
comments that when talking to them it's
like it seems like that someone that
works in the laboratory but then you see
them on stage and it works and you can
recognize that it's comedy that works
that's good but I I'm the same as you I
have Aboriginal right I like people that
are themselves that are and I'm a little
offended by hard work that's perfect I
said that to my therapist today I said
I'm just so angry
sometimes I go because I write now I
realized that I realized that you know
one of the things I've said in therapies
I'd put all my eggs in Travel Channel's
baskets hand like I want I want you to
get me famous mm-hmm and then it and
then it didn't happen and then and then
I I'm not saying I'm famous but I got
myself what I wanted by doing stand-up
and doing a special for Showtime and
promoting it myself by the way I hired
[ __ ] a promotions team to help me
promote it they were [ __ ] useless all
they know how to do is speak jargon
3,000 dollars for a month
[ __ ] wait that that I'm gonna [ __ ]
lose money so don't do that do not do
that okay not do that do anything this
is the Doug Stanhope method call me I'll
tell you everything I did I'll tell you
everything I did right I won't leave one
part out because I don't care about
other people's success I want everyone
to be some [ __ ] successful if you're
funny I want to watch it I don't give a
[ __ ] I'm not like some of these comics
who hide their secrets I don't want you
to know what I did because then I can't
do it more I don't give a [ __ ] and and
and
it was such and one of my things I don't
know where I'm going with this [ __ ]
rant but I put so many eggs in other
people's baskets that I don't know where
the [ __ ] but but I want and then I
realized today it's just me you're
talking about doing it on your own
getting do you doing the Showtime
special rather than depending on Travel
Channel yeah but my point is I was
saying there's so many guys in this
business who their act and their life
reeks of hard work
like I like right now I'm obsessed with
the fact that I go should I be going
back to college to learn how to do
Photoshop or do posters I'm very good
with Photoshop and no that's not the
answer looks like I was like you know
either learned editing myself I had to
learn how to do a podcast myself I do I
have to post I had to learn everything
myself I had to learn I had to go online
and learn how to upload the rain I had
to figure out a 64 megabyte mp3 type
like 64 whatever bps I had to learn all
that myself and I'm like I'm like helmet
when are we going to stop I'm [ __ ]
tired of this man yeah I want to go back
that's what I respect so much in
Chappelle is it's just it's the guy they
didn't want to go to the wedding that
his chick brought him and your chick
brought you and you sat next to him you
loved him I want more calmly like that
yeah the point is I was saying to Chris
Martin Chris Fairbanks that made me
laugh so hard when he's not trying to
make me laugh my favorite story ever
ever because it accentuates all the
people I love in it
me Donnell and red grant are sitting on
the steps to that house and Encino right
so everyone once again a little sidebar
me Chris Amy Schumer regular on Theo von
Kyle sees for a little bit Kyle sees
Jeff Garcia Oh Jeff Kurr see I forgot
Mandel Jeff Garcia decided that wasn't
for him right that's the boldest thing
I've ever I'm like I don't understand it
I need the money
good to meet you John O Donnell wrong
smiley we all understood it wasn't for
us by the first week yeah yeah so this
is a real reality show it's oh okay we
got tricked
okay just want to make sure we all got
tricked
good duly noted let's continue now let's
see that for some
so-called reality bites back where we
were told uh it's a spoof route of Reno
911 HS owed a parody of a specific genre
of reality and so we all signed up I
don't remember the number but I'm gonna
say then I remember what it was per
episode but I'll say it
guessing mmm 10 grand an episode almost
what was it eight heaven point five so
me know you got ten it was a pile of
[ __ ] that I always find that out it was
favored nations seven point five I'm
sure I've told people with sixteen by
this time that's one that's one little
finger talked about if you win at the
end and all of a sudden there is prize
money that would make it they didn't
find out any of this we all just said
great money yeah it's it's a it's a
twelve ten episode order and so all
overall doing the math going 75 grand
that's [ __ ] awesome
I would knew I was getting into
something when they made me run on a
treadmill would cagey suction cups to my
tits like I'm [ __ ] a Russian getting
ready to box that was by the way that
was the lead-in to this is we all went
to the exact same doctor by the way my
still still say my same doctor and we'll
say her name but if you ever need
someone to fudge a [ __ ] physical for
you so that you can get qualified for a
show which I've had 200 K he's really
good yes it's a I couldn't believe might
they're like oh your lung capacity
because I had dabbled with cigarettes at
the time uh so they run us through a
litany of physical exams emotional exams
and Oh couple people who didn't pass the
emotional exam and got booted Wow yeah
from reality bites back
yep I know one girl tell you off air who
got booted who was supposed to do it and
now it's a good story but I won't share
it yeah I guess he can't know really
want it wasn't was it wasn't bad but
it's a good story
it wasn't battled but it they took it
away from him and added someone at the
last minute all right now uh you know
and asked him later
so uh so I'm by the way I'm just
realized that this guy hears this he
thinks I'm I won't tell you who it is
okay I'm not gonna tell you okay I won't
do that because that's not fair okay
cool
all right I'm so sorry that I said that
I won't share it I won't and I am
I promised whoever you are after the
podcast I will not constantly ask who
was it who was it I'm not going to do
that so my promise you stranger so I'm
done so we all tell 10 episodes I have
two children at the time I just had ila
and it's just straight off for no
audition straight on so we get it we're
all excited we go to the first day to
this house and immediately they're like
need your cell phones I need you're
going to all be sitting in this room and
that wouldn't fly now by the way just we
need your cell phones now I can't it's a
computer in my pants it's my email it's
my livelihood sorry sorry but at the
time it was like everything with flip
phones yeah yeah we're like you not
getting my sag kick gonna get booked
sidekick booked the very first day we're
all sitting out there and Kyle sees had
made hats breach that was funny
especially when he left with 12 unmoor
hats each at big 1 week 2 week 3 week 4
week 5 and they were blue with a white
writing if yeah I'm all embroidered and
that was his bit anything he walks on
set and I'm sitting on the stoop on the
stoop of this house on the stairs of
this house with Donnell Rollins and red
Grant who are both black comics and
Donnell is an old-school Baltimore bully
in my opinion to this day and you walk
up with Kyle sees two the two the three
of us walk up casually your hands on
your pants pocket and Kyle goes what's
up fellas and immediately I'm looking at
Donnell he role design he goes that's
right son you are the weak one because
you should just take that one off that
hat and just say weak cuz you're [ __ ]
weak son beat it and how does excuse me
he goes leave leave the son you're
actually just saying weak and Kyle goes
I think they spell weak differently than
the way it's written on my hat and
Donnell goes non Mon neighborhood you're
just weak and you silently are backing
up and I go Chris where you going you go
I think I'm next
[Laughter]
Stiles eyes divert he just started back
Oh God that does I do remember the L
room I didn't remember that before that
story
the report is weaker self neck we find
out the first one we all had to seduce
our parents which was humiliating huh
not for me it was my dad the lights came
out of my dad when you get into town I
forget what I said about my boner
it gives me chill bumps it gives me such
[ __ ] chill bumps because we had taken
remember we had taken this twenty page
test of our sexual past right and so and
we they were like listen this is what
[ __ ] sucks about reality show do it
the more honest you're in this the
better off you have a chance of winning
what AG winning like didn't get it yeah
and then they blind us all up with our
parents and they asked our parents are
most did as your son ever gotten a
[ __ ] in a strip club and you're like
oh that's the game show where they had
to hold up what they thought at that
time yeah and we're like oh my god it's
horrible and then whoever won them and
their mom got to kick someone off and
you came up to me and I think it was me
oh but once I was I was you and Donnell
that we're up to get voted off right or
no for that no no no no you you came up
to me feel Vaughn got to pick yeah and
you said I don't want to go home I need
this money yeah yeah I said I don't
remember going I was driving there in it
comfortable that I borrowed that I had
to hold the roof down on the freeway or
would fly off yeah guy was bro and you
said what do I do and I once it was me
and someone else but I go just tell Theo
not to vote you off and you're like do
you think that'll work and I go it's
worth a shot
and you walked up to here and you go
please don't vote me off I need this
money anyone okay and he he was done fo
you're gonna vote you all you're the one
who's gonna vote on don't be a mob guy
oh yeah oh that's my sorry Kyle you're
listening buddy what right over here do
it please don't vote me off I need this
money anyone okay thank you are like
we don't work oh man if Kyle heard that
I'd probably drive away that is next
motivate I want to say this is this is
part of the reason Kyle got out of
company is that [ __ ] reality show
because do you think all do you remember
we had we had a photo shoot in the
desert oh yeah yeah poor Kyle I love you
to death Kyle but I will say was and
he'll he has to admit it he's a honest
motivational speaker he was spinning the
[ __ ] out about how this was the best
thing that ever happened in his career
yeah and we were and I remember Amy and
you were at a table of them and Amy got
up and sat down there she goes I can't I
can't do that yeah I do remember now he
was having a bit which was weird because
up till that point he had been like this
great level had a guy that only says
encouraging things I wish I it's more
like that and then that day he was
having trouble yeah I remember that yeah
and then Donnell I don't think let up on
him Donnell course not Darnell was
brutal do you remember being in the van
when he told mo he wasn't funny uh-oh
that would make my own that was having
mo said I could beat up everyone here
and and then mo Donnell goes but this is
a bet one of my other favorite moments
in this we're all sitting in a van
driving down the 101 and most just he's
young and - he's cracking jokes and
Donnell says mo you're not funny and Mo
goes I'm funny as [ __ ] Donnell one of
the new Arnie there's nothing not funny
to me
Oh has anyone in your life ever told you
here floody and did all serious oh no
yes of course
my mom and we Oh God Austin I how do you
have this memory I read and ever that
was the I was losing my mind on the
thing no - I was like because I'm very
self hating I keep it all inside and
until the right person comes along I
drove you I died but Amy and mine - Pheo
and Mo and my wife's Mercedes down to
the so you think you could dive yeah and
you said on the ride down
Wow there's gonna be awkward for whoever
gets voted off here like whoever voted
off you should just say I won't ride in
this car and I got voted off and I had
to drive all of you
oh yeah yeah that was weird how you got
voted off because it was almost like
wait I offended in real life Greg
Louganis by dancing seductively he was
like you know that's really offensive to
dance seductively in a mocking way to a
gay man and you were like is it wet and
we were all I guess it come we're
learning you call about rofo oh he
wanted ever been voted off expected in
the locker and they had us all put on
like nude little g-strings and you were
like who saw greco gave us as a hetero
folk if you Amy and Eli think really
kind of partnered off and became like
best friends during that yeah because I
remember the first night they allowed us
to go home if we wanted to go home and I
had kids so I went home yeah you Theo
and Amy went over went over to a bar
right oh yeah yeah on Sunset yeah we
believe I remember more of the show than
anybody
uh I don't I'm my brain I don't remember
much no seriously yesterday yeah I worry
about it
I was Alzheimer's in my family I really
scrutinize everything that I forget oh
we I'm worried about when our moms were
there we all stayed we got so [ __ ] up
that night I remember I remember so much
of that show because it was the most fun
it's it's you know you have it I bought
it on iTunes if you ever Oh because I
don't think anyone has a cop Comedy
Central I think didn't like the
viewership it got like the first ever
negative ratings reelers I don't know it
by the way I live now right now that
Tiffany Haddish was on the show also he
was talking about right now
that show is [ __ ] one of the most
would be one of the most sellable shows
on television Oh totally it was just I
always thought even at the time that it
was ahead of its time and people maybe
weren't ready to see what was the most
popular teletype of television at that
point being spoofed yeah now everyone
would make fun of some version of it
that was Kardashians or but you know
like the people are ready to make fun of
reality and all the people that
we worked with are now working in
television and on much bigger scales one
of the guys was our producer our story
producers is is time to point out yeah
yeah yeah it's fun it's really kind of
fun insane but and has been this whole
time that was a long time ago now this
is pretty tough I know that show really
yeah those guys then lent so that's when
Daniel got his show right after that and
so this was oh wait oh well I figure
I'll it was probably just been born she
was born in those six so it's Mario 708
yeah your children were walking with as
I recall inside that what's really sad
is I don't remember anything about my
children right at times but I do
remember and now I do remember you Amy
and bo calling each other they party
starters and then who did oh I one night
after a few drinks I'd tread
I did some of those jokes to Darren
Carter like I wrote a song with the ov
on called Darren carne for the party
starter do you want to hear it I kind of
wish I could have taken that back is
such a nice guy it was exotic Bobby
started Darren kadhi party started get
hit right to his face no I was not he's
a good sport though he's like I like it
that's funny oh remember I could draw
from memory the way your apartment you
lived I Drive by it sometimes by
Cantor's wasn't it yeah yeah yeah yeah
like uh Bert still in there I didn't
know you're here at this house now I
know where to drive by all but I think
we all went to the I want to say we all
went to the any common central Emmy
party together oh yeah we went to we did
yeah yeah Ron yay was there to it
everyone camber that yeah yeah but no
one gave a [ __ ] about at that time D
raised friend oh wow used him and DeRay
Davis started together I'm having Tonya
tried to do stand-up - oh my god a rap
and so and I knew I liked his album I'd
seen him on the Chappelle show and I
liked him and I but I was like hey like
all hip-hop guys I was like he'll fade
away yeah good good first album oh I
think the second I'll probably come out
and I was like alright yeah yeah whoo
[ __ ] sauna and yeah I'll never attack
at that party there was a very very
famous comic that got busted for drugs
who came up and tried to get me to do
drugs with him oh I think I might have
that you can tell me after the show yeah
I'll definitely tell you sir I did rowdy
powder that night all night yeah and I
go getting that didn't but that that uh
that was a that that show was so I
remember so vividly so much about it and
then I remember I remember uh you ended
up getting a car after that you got a
100 court yeah that's what I spent my
money on yeah it's kind of weird that I
remember the things I remember so
there's such a grip remember Lincoln all
right yeah yeah that number Amy Schumer
sweats from her armpits aggressively
he sang end up spending so much time
with them it's like like Amy and I was
so not I mean I must say you think we
could talk her into the reality bites
reunion to her to talk her into giving
us her phone number anymore
do you ever phone her buddy was uh yeah
but last time I saw her she was staying
in Venice and she was writing a movie
and I'm like that sounds hard good luck
with that but it was that train rolling
right now she's the same number bonus
okay pocket let's see if I do have it
what's called tell me if you have the
same number I got okay oh and that I was
a twin at your house and I met your wife
and kids that's when I got a call from
my bank that said did you uh I probably
shouldn't even tell that story
someone tried to spend like ten thousand
dollars on my debit card look and I
think at that point the money was there
so I was but they turned him down but I
had a horrible thing happen in Florida
that was a little to do with drugs
assuming you got I got five one six I
got five we click serious another save
number lesbo texture he does both
texture the same picture of us I'm not
going to college soon
I'm concerting she has lawyers to go
take that podcast down alright yeah like
it like we on why I do that you don't
want to put her on a podcast but will
text your pictures I don't know what to
say to a right now
the exact same picture okay of what I
don't have the same pictures in my phone
as you right now I'm almost certain oh
never mind what the left to last text I
sent her I guess she was doing a
screening for um well didn't you have a
fight with her about something no no
okay I'm thinking of someone else
yeah no I would never I've never I've
been I hadn't talked to the last text I
sent her I was going to she was doing a
screening for LeBron and Akron for him
and his friends and I happened to be in
Akron that night Oh
and I was like and I was like hey I did
the last text I just read it I was like
I'm gonna be in Akron I'd love to come
see your movie trainwreck and no reply
and then I wrote Bert okay and no reply
so I'm yeah that's not technically
inside no no we I mean mystically I
wouldn't say close I think I would still
say that I like if someone said are you
friends with Chris Fairbanks I go oh
very good
like I would I would think I could call
you and go hey buddies come to your show
my can I get him free tickets exactly
yeah I wouldn't throw that you Eddie my
friends are in this business but um you
know I think when you get that big I
think that I think that you just got to
pick a tight group yeah I don't know I'm
so proud of her I really am and but yeah
I don't I wouldn't feel that made me
nervous to think it's a I like if people
looked at me like that
yeah you're people were nervous to call
me I've always said and I will never ask
for anything from anyone now look like
anything from her oh yeah there's any
other one think we have any crossover
fans I'd actually think the exact
opposite I think my fans are the people
who don't like her right you know the
people who are like like they're like
people are getting honor about that step
people love to attack someone who's on
top and if you thought is really hard on
Iran they didn't but no they want you to
be precious they want to think they want
to discover you and find you to be
precious and then they want to destroy
it they want to they want to destroy it
I can't they did it with gain remember
they haven't destroyed Dane I saw him
the other day all I know is that his
chick in his car I'd [ __ ] either of them
just the tailpipe yeah I would
definitely plug his car like this I'm up
against the seas until I came see and
he's very grounded he's looking big and
scary Wolverine he likes hate looking
[ __ ] you I think he's Juicin
I'm from the 70s and I think he's Juicin
on the Jews he is so he I don't know the
guy very well I have I know Dane well I
would say I I'll tell you what
I texted Danny of the dancer named I
love you on the podcast and immediately
he was like I love to be on the podcast
yeah unless I wouldn't be intimidated to
call Dane I've called Dana bunch times
in like but I'm there's a I'm not
intimidated called bur I wouldn't call
Louie I'm intimidated to call a tell but
that's because I look him as a hero but
I did text him the other day and he
replied immediately I'd call a towel
yeah else the bet he's telling her to
tell him Stanhope are like Stanhope all
tiny went with a low self-esteem Hong
Kong yeah a taillights himself calm
right now it's so funny that like that
Amy someone that we knew that you would
I wouldn't have been dance that he would
had a hard time reaching out to her I so
the so bizarre yeah you know but I guess
you become something bigger and I guess
you have so many people attacking you
and then I don't think she's working
hard always I think that she's like
working here at yeah I look at her
Instagram she's always in a pool oh
really
I'm kidding I know but years ago when I
try though before all this stuff started
to happen at the improv she was like
what are you doing if there's you should
be doing this and this you need to apply
yourself more yet and I was like faculty
and then I watched this hat I think she
just made a decision to be like I'm
going to make this happen whereas I've
never done that like I stand the hard
work thing I'm not I'm I'm like turned
off by him not now though I'm trying to
work harder what are you getting the
comedy though I mean I thought the
reason when I started I the reason you
got in the comedy was so you have to
work right it's like I just want to sit
and think about funny stuff and and
maybe get a little high get drunk at the
end of the night sleep in I don't know I
already had I was already doing
freelance
art stuff kind of struggling in the same
way whereas like trying to get another
illustration get trying to get some do a
skateboard graphic or something and it
was hard to get consistent work it was
great training for the inconsistency of
a comedy career but I wasn't yeah so I
that wasn't I would love to have
consistency but yeah I haven't didn't do
it won't do I would dig at the time oh
yeah yeah I'm supposed to go see her
babies she has babies two of them they
look the sections they call them twins
which how do you have twins you just
adopt kids I'm not I'm not a hundred a
time they had them I'm not a hundred
percent sure they went through so many
options and I haven't specifically asked
if it's frozen eggs or or I think it's a
third-party pregnant person
neither Tigger Steph's not pregnant [ __ ]
but it was planned and they knew ahead
of time it was going to be twins and all
that does yeah I just saw her in uh in
Henry Phillips pretty awful I have these
about once a month
that's fresh just greens with lemon
juice oh just greens for real like yeah
I mean just smell it probably zero oh
it's like oh it's legit where do you get
this this is great I get this at rainbow
acres it says it right there and they
make it in-house now and I have a once a
month because it takes me a month to
forget how horrible it tastes weird I
live in Venice
you still invented me are you still
skating down there I can't I have to get
both my hips replaced with surgery that
I watched on YouTube which I do not if
you're out there and you need hips do
not immediately watch that doctor at his
request psycho to watch the surgery it's
violent listen to me it's violent
there's poundings
there are bone fragments and I think I
saw some one guy was wearing ski goggles
you guys come bend your leg you're
absolute fan your leg sideways like this
so imagine your leg then they rotate it
until it just pops out of the head oh
yeah Chris s Getty hip replacement
I'm getting one hip replaced in May yeah
I'm getting it I'm getting preparing
mentally for it but I am I know how they
do it they put you asleep
know that I would rather have now and
then they replace it with metal mine is
they put a little helmet like a Ralph s
Mouse helmet on top of your femur and
drill down it like a bedpost but to get
at it they need to basically pull your
leg out and set it next you and I
watched I watched on YouTube they
there's two big dudes that bend your leg
like that and pop it out and it makes a
loud popping noise and then they hammer
at it to get oh yeah why'd I watch it
then it's not like I'm going to be the
doctor told him you should watch says
look Brazil is worried about you now I
know both had rented both hips oh just a
gift from God I don't I I didn't do
anything apparently wasn't from
skateboarding it didn't help but I'm I
was born with they said my hips were
off-center like a melted ice cream cone
I think I'm a good doctor pelvic Brody
Stevens got a tilted pelvic oh yeah he
says it I think he said it's why he
walks feminine I well I always kind of
ran like Tom Cruise if that counts
very rat like that kind of Mission
Impossible with Oh
choppy hands and then apparently that's
the exciting thing as you walk out of
surgery yeah and I'll be swimming the
next week and yeah it's it's not as is
it invasive as or the surgery is but the
recovery is better than like a knee
surgery sometimes so I'm that's why I'm
excited I want the relief I want that
yeah I hope you do I'm grumpy yelling at
people really yeah yeah I need it to
happen and then I'll do this one at the
end of the year really I'm going to
Minos Oh a lot well the guy does it
every Wednesday every Wednesday it's 50
to 100 grand a week
like five why didn't I just do a little
better I took
science in college I just didn't apply I
didn't memorize things I just memorized
things but I found this guy because I'm
in my mind I thought there was a doctor
out there that would sculpt bone like
use your existing bones and chisel at
them with a powdered wig and that's how
I found the guy he is a sculptor we walk
into his office he is like a marble
skeleton that he made and they're
assuming perfect he's an artist guys
entering an artist and then he's a witch
do you do you agree that that's kind of
I wanted the guy that's like
passionately paying attention like a
like a sculptor yeah we had a we had we
had a tooth doctor who my mom said he's
an artist yeah I was saying he made all
my teeth all my teeth are fake sure so I
gotta get them redone and I'm flying to
Tampa I thanks no I'm I'm honestly
looking forward to I wish I didn't watch
the video but I'm looking forward to the
yeah had to have both hips replaced in
her 50s which is I mean you're way
younger than that but it was still so
young but she was like I was a
completely different human being that's
all I've heard from anyone and I've
called he gave me the numbers to some of
the people because he has like a Wall of
Fame and one of the guys any famous
people a filmer no just a guy that back
when I snowboarded he was a snowboard
video guy and and he got the same
procedure on both hips just a few months
apart and he said do it even if it's
preemptively even if you don't think
you're ready do it because he said for
the first time ever he's sitting
cross-legged falling asleep with his
knee touching the mattress things like
what did he fall asleep you know how for
me at least I I'm just flying right now
just for visual I'm flashing my groin at
a married couple I uh like like that
like sitting like that that's very
uncomfortable for me to Josie I couldn't
do this oh not with this lady I can't
even put this shoe on without getting
without going like that I can't
so skateboarding is out of the question
I can't holy [ __ ] so once but once I get
that doesn't apparently all the
back and I'm gonna you'll see I'm gonna
have a skateboard career comeback in my
mid yeah exactly yeah yeah and then I'll
roll around in a cart i guy it makes me
happy I'm gonna wear it out oh I don't
want to think about that yeah I did it
too soon all right
Leon's gonna start a new podcast called
off mic just comes in and talks off mic
see that's when see on your zoom not to
talk sharp but there is a mic on top
picks up the nose but I did that's how
you get the honks and get out of my way
sounded too much yeah um you start doing
that that's not a bad idea well you can
lay it down just in case something
happens in the so wait so does health
insurance pay for this yeah it was good
timing for me to get sag insurance sag
insurance nice yeah so that's also why
I'm like well time to do it now because
if I don't get another commercial or
whatever which is kind of how I
privately make my money because private
or secretly I'm the commercials I'm in
their eyes in Canada I used to do used
to do some uh like tour posters or art
show for for comics to do I've been
doing that a lot lately added one third
Dana Gould and was a bobcat this one
just a show in Portland I think I saw
the people the lumberjack and that was
so [ __ ] great oh thanks man just saw
that I just saw that I was like that is
so [ __ ] bad ow
thanks man yeah I did that I've been
drawing a bunch of stuff lately and I'm
trying to get more into my plan because
that's my plan B what just not it's
always nice to have another plan it's
always let me tell you something that
I'm in that headspace right now not with
uh but just looking at it like bright
orange going good but like look what can
I do also like what's my also fit move
like it's not just for mental health
because you can't you literally it's
like I remember I so funny I saw I said
this to Leon yesterday where we walk
over in North Hollywood Park every
morning mm-hmm
and I saw this black dude walking
towards me who's running lines I was
jogging and he was running lines who's
running lines yeah yeah and I thought I
got really [ __ ] depressed and I went
I remember being there when all my eggs
were in the better book TV show compass'
c't right I'm not saying a lot of eggs
and baskets today but like I remember I
had money and I was running out of money
and I in my my everyone's like you got a
book something that energy is so not
enjoyable then - last week I was in at a
meeting was this company uh I think they
listen to podcasts well but I won't say
their names now now but a very big
company that anyone else would be very
nervous in mmm but in my head I want I
don't need this
like I I mean I want this I want this to
end up if we have full control would
stand up and then there is no time cap
on it it doesn't matter if we get older
all that acting stuff it's like we'd be
putting on wrinkle cream it's not a
healthy thing that's to worry about
notice I do have wrinkle cream and I
just bought a new face it electrocutes
your jawline are you serious I'm gonna
be tall you got some of the luxuries
your jawline yeah yeah it's shocking you
can't really feel it you put on a serum
I just got it I just got started with it
by the way I will shave my figured if I
knew that I could type much all very
embarrassed then I'm telling you about
it it was going to be even private and
the girl I'm saying so yeah anyway yeah
I have I have a new face and I'm going
to shock myself until I look like a boy
again
okay well it's funny because I said
maybe eight months ago I'm guessing
we're renovating the house I I knew what
my projected income could be hmm I had
not technically monetized my podcast and
I and I was in a car with a manager of a
club and numbers were not good and I was
not going to hit any bonus I was just
gonna get the bare minimum but where
were ya st. Louis
home of Greg of war warrant kept that
today I was going to mention him earlier
because he's someone that had a full on
he gave up a full on either
pharmaceutical industry or some
investment he made a lot of money with a
real job that he really at the peak of
its success and his success in that job
quit to do stand-up in Houston and I
remember us you know come in LA through
mark Babbitt the guy used to run the
laugh stop which is no longer but it was
the best and I I couldn't believe that
he was a guy that had saved money and
had owned a house and everything from
his job before a stand-up and then quit
but he committed he really yeah yeah I
he's so funny though yeah he he's a
really interesting guy
you know I find him fascinating I mean
so talented and then on top of it you
look at he is ax murderers here's people
anyone with cauliflower ear so that
would anyone would cauliflower course
you should of course they didn't get
that from rolling down a window too fast
streak oh that I'm combat cauliflower
years from sleeping too hard because my
ear guts what would you have your
fingers crossed like oh please please
please
yeah yeah this guy's a badass no he just
asked for yeah yeah
now I turns out I had the wrong pillow
so wait wait I want to finish this but I
want to go back to Houston yeah I keep
laying around but no no but but uh we're
talking about the plan B and all I'm
saying is I had a moment in st. Louis
where I was sitting with the manager and
he just was like so what are you gonna
do when you what are you gonna do when
you turn 50 I'm 44 I was 43 at the time
hmm I like what he's like you're not
gonna do stand-up are ya
I know when I went my boner said that I
had panic and in my no note as a manager
but he was I know it might have been the
guy just driving me a radio but he but
he wasn't saying it to be a dick he was
saying it like based on your numbers
this weekend and on the trajectory we
were looking at both of us honestly hmm
are you really going to walk away from
Travel Channel and just do stand-up
because like you know you don't know you
might end up being up
producer of something I had panic sit in
my heart all weekend and I thought to
myself I better be cool with this yeah
yeah better and then that I am get don't
you like stand up more never right oh
god I [ __ ] love it my - I like I said
- someone offered me some TV show that
I'd obviously didn't want to do and then
they were like how much and I gave him a
number as a ridiculous number and I
couldn't were going to pay you that was
like cool right then that makes a
decision so much easier because I go if
it was that this is that number I'd feel
like I thought tell if I'd have to take
it yeah maybe that [ __ ] number Craig
that's how I got birth of concur when we
did when we did the first round of
negotiations they gave us a number and I
was like I'm gonna pass they're never
going to pay me what I want and then
they go write down a number lands like
write down a number and I wrote down a
number and she goes oh yeah they give
you that and then they did know was like
well looks like I'm doing Brooke concur
but yet what you wish the number had
been higher then it came up with you
know is their first offer was that
number no huh I'll accept it yeah and so
it wasn't a ton of money but it was a
lot more it was it was a it was just
around what we had gotten paid for
sharing it like like probably my first
number I was like did they give me that
that I can't because I wouldn't make
that on the road right right all right I
forgot that you started because I know
you're from Montana I forgot that you
started in Texas with those guys yeah
yeah I started in Austin with a Brenda
Walsh with Brit yeah Brendan actually
hadn't he was hanging out and doing
sketches would like this duo and Ian
Leon and he had tried stand-up I think
earlier on but didn't like there was a
bully factor with the older comics in
Austin like turn off the mic in the back
of the room heckle you from a second mic
why I like want to fight everyone I
moved to Texas and I was like I'm that's
very hostile now it's so welcoming and
we and what happen about that yeah well
those guys are all my friends now so I
don't you know I want too much [ __ ]
about because now these guys these older
comics that maybe don't do it that much
anymore come and see me when I'm
visiting town they're like good friends
now but when I first moved in one name
of one guy I mean I would Howard Beecher
knows he's one of them he's
best well how are we turned like Howard
Kramer they were there they're like
early Austin common or you know and I
probably the Herbie's arrived uh
Beatrice the best I love him that any
like he always gave me advice and it was
always like really he's just hilarious I
like the guy a lot but at the time like
they would Google in Howard Beach or
they would know him oh he's got a full
on other career he's I don't know that
he's I think it does like corporate
events and but man those guys they as a
young comic because I was maybe the new
young guy was it was a it was hard at
the the velvety room it was a lot of
hecklers it was a poet Oh hostile men so
then the laugh stop I was drive there
and get real like feature work and you
know open Ferb Dane Cook there and greg
Giraldo and David Cross and Wanda Sykes
all these comics that I would have never
otherwise where quests I'm it's that
Houston scene which there is no scene in
Houston Houston comedy scene was the
best the rolling reason I ever my first
headlining opportunity came at the
Houston laptop Dane Cook
bailed out oh yeah and they were like we
need something to fill can you get to
Houston today
do you mind wearing a tight black muscle
shirt they want to feel the exact void
to wear a words they were not they were
so trying to fill that void identically
because Gary Goldman was there as his
feature and Gary was like why don't I
just headline and they're like you don't
act like Dane this guy Diaz you have -
chokes about grapefruit sir no they were
looking at it were literally like we
want Dane like yeah yeah so they brought
me in and they were the guys like you're
high energy people all I see I guess I
wanna see right and I was like Kenny
goes okay and so I was like what Mark
Babbitt said that or was it really
yeah other guy yeah I wasn't there when
Babbitt was I was only there was real
he's a better business person maybe I
don't know but it did fail under his
watch
Babbitt was a passionate art like comedy
here
Rayner you know he was I think he was by
the way I'm if Babbitt never hears us
you know I love you Babbitt but uh he's
I think he was until he went to the
improv I think once when he lost his
passion sheriff because I was so pumped
to meet him mmm and I went in with J
Moore and I said to him I said hey I'm
such a pleasure to meet you I've heard
so many great stories and I was like if
you get a chance to look at my set or
see anything and doing this lazy or
anything please like give me a heads up
and he's like yeah and he was in his
office and I went back at the end and to
his in his office and he was still in
his office I said in little needle
position I said what did you think and
he goes I'm not gonna watch you this
week like I was like really good jobs
I'm sorry man yeah he did lose the
passion then he cuz he used to really
I'd be bombing on his stage and he'd be
laughing is like I don't care keep doing
that weird [ __ ] oh I wanted I wanted
that because there were so many good
badass story but he was such he
literally like a part of him I feel like
nurtured if not nuzzled the career of
like Mitch Hedberg mm-hmm I think a lot
to do at Mitch's scream mark Babbitt for
everyone who doesn't know real quick can
you give a like a synopsis I don't think
I did totally but mark Babbitt uh
managed in both the the Houston laughs
table he's also the guy that like
installed a sound system so guys could
record CDs right and it was a
state-of-the-art sound system in the 90s
which is saying a lot that's like a lot
of money to give comics you could go in
and request albums from that laptop hmm
it's so bad it's just me doing Mexican
jokes cuz that's all that would come out
okay right yeah yeah but mark Babbitt
was the [ __ ] best you know he prolly
was great to me also he overpaid me he
same with me because he'd celled a
competitive thing with selling the shoes
of Babbitt they had a animosity towards
each other I think and then I thought I
don't even think Pete likes me he just
books me here more than Babbitt did as
out of competition for he's like I like
you too
what do you think out like you as much
as a bit did so it who was the group it
was the big group it was like these are
the Texas comics I can think of off the
top of my head
bigger staff Shari McRae those are
Houston guys yeah uh McRae's minor Walsh
yep Brandon pyro Howard Kramer I know
that like the I start with Martha Kelly
who's now she was gone for a while and
now she's on that baskets show because I
just saw a picture of her yeah she was
like doing data entry or something I
think in Zach Galifianakis who's great
was like you're going to be on the show
and she was very she's like I don't want
to be the Jar Jar Binks of a show of a
comedy show I was hurt the quote I think
it's funny
um but yeah she's she's doing great now
and I couldn't be so what did you let
lol balloon and I most Michelle balloon
yeah she started in Austin Jim Hamilton
started in Austin plant there's a
missing huge that was my group of
friends though really went yeah Brendon
and Michelle and Martha and George all
had day jobs
I didn't I just drawn pictures I was
doing signs painting side painting
windows really mattress sale you know I
was painting windows a lot in mural
there's still walls in Austin that I
have my urn on him like that was I had
an OK career going on there that I kind
of found it difficult to follow it up
here in LA cuz in Austin that there's
art everywhere there's a mural oh you
want to spray paint the inside of my
restaurant sure like it's that art
severe most annoyingly everybody did you
see spell special in Austin not yet no I
heard x-ray my roommate now I've I did a
review on my last podcast by know he'd
released two specials I was an idiot I
thought it was one special he didn't two
special yeah there's one they're not and
one in Atlanta or something one an
offset of one in uh no it's not Atlanta
I won't say don't know where it is
dammit I wish I should know here's a
pretty good story though Babbitt called
me one day and he said hey I was in
Austin visiting night or a moved here
but he said that you have to go to the
hospital right now
mitch is they want he said a driving a
car a barrier they're good they need to
amputate Mitch's leg you have to go
there and talk him into letting them
amputate his leg or he'll die of
gangrene or something I'm like what do
you
what I don't even know this guy i opened
from once that the last up and and so I
went there and he was like handcuffed to
a bed they had had drugs or something
heroin or something he got arrested but
he is like and it smelled like meat
rotten meat and I was like hey you don't
know me but you know mark Babbitt he's
like no I remember your comic and I said
mark sent me here and they say blow this
story down usually so Mitch's hand cup
to a better they're cops in the room
know he's in there by child and it's
just mentioned and Lynn's purse like I
can I tell you real quickly you're
telling is the one story I wanted to
hear more in my life in stand-up comedy
ever well it doesn't have a huge its
payoff hold on doesn't matter so it
slowed it down because I air more than
I've listened to anything I've ever
listened to on my podcast more than what
I'm going to do is I'm going to take a
portion of that clip at 57 seconds and
put at the very beginning because I
can't [ __ ] wait I wanna know every
detail okay you're in Houston
I showed up because Babbitt called me
and said you have to go to a hostel in
Austin actually he knew I was in Austin
he was driving from Houston in a panic
called me in a panic and said yeah very
quickly rambling Lee said he need to cut
his leg off and he won't let him cut his
leg they'll cut his leg off he'll die
and I'm like what do you sounds like a
civil war problem and I show so I show
up and I said yes I'm are you family I
said yes I'm his brother they didn't
check my ID I got brought into a room
he's pretty much asleep there's blood on
the pillow he bleeding I don't know why
out of his mouth like a pink maybe it
was he was hooked up to something he was
handcuffed to the bed and it smelled
I'll never forget how it smelled he had
problems with it's like is can you see
the leg at all now it's covered with the
blanket but there's blood in the sheets
really yeah is live in the room no but
her stuff was there I don't know exactly
just but
really she's my friend and I don't know
if I should be flippantly telling the
story but looks is like having a lookout
so they were in trouble I will say this
about Lin I ran an island with a shawl
in it the stand up there and then meters
I did help lingo
Hennigan and she I think Shelley was
there I don't I don't know if I was it
and and I said to Lin very casually um
she she might have said this is a very
Lin ism she might have said you know I
used to be married to Mitch and I went I
know exactly the [ __ ] you are yeah like
you do and I was like Lin I may be the
biggest Mitch Hedberg fan in the world
she's like oh my god why wouldn't you
tell me that my go cuz I can't [ __ ]
sit here he gout about Mitch to you
because I think it's an appropriate she
goes I loved him right in front edge on
door yeah go yeah your ex ah yeah and I
go I go I loved I loved him she was I
loved him you can ask me any question
you want to ask me and I was like I
can't do that
because then I will pull you off to the
side of the comedy store and I would
just be drilling you about Mitch and
that yeah no Priya I just want to let
you know I loved him and so I don't
think she'd have a problem sharing the
story no and and she employed she had me
do art she had me draw pictures of him
she's like I want to Mitch skateboard
you know she was before they even the
funeral but aim so he's alive at this
point of ISM and then I just say this
clunk like your buddy mark called me I'm
just here on his behalf he wanted me to
tell you that if there is any doubt in
your mind of whether or not to let them
do this amputation need still I think I
was like you're not an athlete you'd
still be this great comic with one leg
it's a weird thing to say and he's like
yeah I know
sure man I just want to get a second
opinion and uh and then and and you
fumbling through yeah you're like oh
yeah I mean Who am I Who am I we did
that we did there was a roast at The
Improv for Mark Abbott and Mike McCrae
did an impression of me and I did Mitch
I don't know who you are or was he just
yeah and he did get a second opinion
and they did they grafted some baby
foreskins on him he didn't get his leg
amputated they did they did some put
skin on him with with another doctor so
he was just like no I think I'm
logically going to go sleep iris couple
I thought yeah I bleep everyone at least
11 people he's going to business and use
light him one of that's always his
solution even now you gotta cut the leg
off but it's a hip surgery
I'm just getting my hip replaced nah cut
it off it's the only answer the advice I
give everyone
he'll be fine with one leg oh my GABA he
but he lived he lived almost a year
after that but that was uh it was just a
year after that yeah it wasn't much he
got better everyone's on and then he got
popped at the airport I think this was
that the dope that no but that is that
how it started aft at the airport but
more importantly they realized also your
leg is going south let's focus on that
really well you're still in trouble and
that so that's why I didn't know at that
time why I was handcuffed how hard could
it be I mean everyone smuggles weed how
hard is it to smuggle heroin um I don't
know may it may be the diabetes it was
the smell of it to these dogs was being
masked by the smell of his legs because
it was real specific you see
yeah gangrenous leg I mean it was real
specific it's like Oh someone needs to
clean up this butcher shop smell and I
that's too crass it was smelling like
really yeah but I did you ever see him
after that nope no I saw him perform and
on stage and I he was just having drinks
but he was like not did you know yeah
what was it like working with him ah I
just did my son and then at the end I'm
like I hope he likes me and then it gave
me a handful of money of his own money
he always if you open for him
and a lot of times he has comic like
comics I'm not certainly not going to
name names but people that were funny at
their own expense like bizarre people
that did stand-up that he would put up I
don't think he'd like to follow like a
strong high-energy or someone that's
going to swear a lot or do you know you
just put someone up but always would
give them hundreds of dollars like
thanks for opening for me this is before
there's like a line around the club he
was very generous really yeah he and
Lynn is still that way they're just
generous yet I only met him one time
and I wouldn't even consider it meeting
him visit the improv he was in blue
sunglasses his fingernails were painted
hmm and I remember thinking the mice I'm
a pertain to myself and I forget who I
said it to must be I must have been
someone that worked with him but I said
I want to get to that place in my career
and they're like what you can dress
you're a rock star I said no I go the
second he goes on says I want you set I
know the second he goes on stage like no
one remembers anything that was said
before him right I go I want to get
there and they were like oh no that's
not much at all Mitch's just like us
they're like he also is worried about
who's following sharing and like he's a
regular guy I was like no they're like
no no and they're like you know he
actually has bad sets a lot did you see
the unedited version of his special
you'd for a while you could watch both
the special that made him famous I think
that Mitch put together it's not one
before that and then there's a version
that was unedited and the audience was
terrible and his constantly was saying
this is not very special like he was
like not English yeah it was not going
well but then it was like a crowd that
didn't get him and in spite of that with
some editing it was the special that
made him who were they getting at the
time by men yeah I don't know it was of
you around the month it wasn't around
when Mitch was around I think yeah I
think in Austin those were the two maybe
it was slightly after that Mencia was
becoming super famous but they both
would have at
cap city in Austin they would have huge
crowds both those that big then I guess
he's probably big in clubs among like
Latino community share but now he wasn't
like the bizarreness like white comics
to it look you remember being at the
close see I was just in New York so all
I knew was at that time was like and
this is by the way just like Chapelle
Breuer like these are the guys that like
Dave Attell Jim Norton like those are
people still the people that inspired me
though around that time that I would
watch for like Eddie Gosling or he got
Robert Hawkins those guys made I'm like
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna do do you ever
see Hawkins but uh he made me laugh so
hard never met Hawkins
but he was one of those guys that that
when people felt like when I found when
I started doing the road for like real
road like not just like do a you know I
never really considered laughs stop the
road because it was such a comic
community yeah yeah like road where they
flew in a feature the feature drove in
yeah was penguins in in Bettendorf Iowa
and the first person I worked with his
Tommy John Egan oh and and I was the
[ __ ] man I was [ __ ] I've been on TV a
couple times yeah I opened for J Moore I
was a destroyer I was [ __ ] murderous
and Tommy John again blew me off the
stage and I was like I remember being
like I must have been so raw to whatever
emotion I brought to him like dude who
the [ __ ] are you
let he's got an even and he was so good
thanks he was even younger looking and
like I remember his opening jacket Joe
joke was something about like I had I
had a stripper so ugly she asked me what
I wanted her to take off he said my
glasses
haha and I was like that's great writing
and like and and I said to him I was
like and the I think I'm whatever I said
must have come out I'm sure he would say
it didn't must come out a tad bit
arrogant or like just just made and he
said there's a lot
killers on the road and he went through
a list in Robert Hawkins was number one
on the list yeah then I started like any
time he came up on Sirius XM that's how
long ago this is listening that all the
time it's within a podcast back then I'd
[ __ ] lose my [ __ ] I'd be like god
damn is funny and then I'd find him
online I was like this funny and so I
ran into Marc Maron at the American
Airlines Airport mmm American Airlines
Admirals Club and mérida just started
WTF ah a nice and and men primarily deep
in a depression around that you know
hadn't blown up yet at all is a real
regular raw nerve
he's always a raw nerve like you know I
don't think there's a time and I've
known there in a long time I could still
do this but back then he was very
successful to the peps a little bit as
I'd go in and tell him what I thought of
the podcast because he didn't know what
he was he knew what he was doing but he
was like taking notes and I was like
dude great one with that guy Eagle ha
like what this great road guy and I go
more of that [ __ ] he was like really I
said dude I go those interviews with
those guys I forget the guys name but it
was such a [ __ ] fascinating interview
I go you know you need to get on here is
Robert Hawkins yes really I said [ __ ]
yeah did he know he went yeah so he
reaches out maybe he did maybe he didn't
I think he did he lived here and was on
and worked produced wrote on that
tightest show that Chris Titus showed
that was why he lived here and they
moved away he's like just on the road
yeah and I said and if you listen to the
beginning of the Marc Maron Robert
Hawkins interview he says I appreciate
you coming and he was like thanks I
really unexpected he goes we'll I ran
into Bert Kreischer and he said you know
you got to get on Robert Hawkins and he
was like really he's and Marin's like
you can thank Bert [ __ ] Chrysler
Thank You Bert [ __ ] Christ never
[ __ ] met him but still one of those
guys that it's just I enjoy comedy it's
so great yeah yeah he's an interesting
dude he hideth actually looks like such
a militant like he could tear your face
off but he's just key and Gosling but I
just saw them and there was utter
silliness they're not they were so
ridiculous and goofy on stage and that's
what I've always liked about and that
that's what I like to build
I love I love I love watching Rogan and
burr sharing they're not they're not
over-the-top silly and goofy now they're
like wait a glass like that makes me
giggle so [ __ ] hard I'm like I know I
won't offend any when I say this I
almost think Megan's funnier Meghan his
wife oh really yeah
she makes me laugh so [ __ ] hard I can
watch anything she's done Oh Meghan yeah
Mooney J sorry I didn't know we jumped a
gun yeah she's yeah I wish sorry I don't
know if she's I mean they she's a mom
and I don't know if she's doing stand-up
much now it's I think about all time
that's a [ __ ] sin if she's not doing
I'm gonna look at where they started
dating I was like I wanted them that's
never happened in my life where I wanted
them to date and then they did end up
dating I knew they'd likely change right
I don't know meg Meg Han Moony moody
yeah they're in an eddy of course it's
been on tosh point-o that whole time but
he when he when I first saw him and he
was he was Ralph almost Ralphie May big
like he was zoom I didn't know that it
used to be fat are you see he used to be
on real big but he still could run I
some run and jump over a picnic table at
that size like he was an athlete inside
like it's not with an H Megan Mooney by
the way that's not her she had this is
her I'm gonna find her real quick
Megan Moody I'm gonna tell you her tour
dates because this is someone if she is
doing any clubs and I don't think she
thinks I thinks gosh she's doing quiet
[ __ ] just look at now she's my age
are you [ __ ] me because she was so
[ __ ] young phishing website of mega
Mooney God man she is she on to her her
website's expired that's why I think
[ __ ] I know I know that it's always it
was like that was skateboarding with me
too like there'd be these kids that I
know that we're a little older they were
so good at it and I wanted to be as good
as them and then they just stopped and
started playing basketball or seeing
girls those girls in skateboarding where
it's anonymous back then but and I was
like well what if they aren't doing it
why am I still
doing it like when someone that's really
good quits it's hard to I mean you know
when I went in I went in and my buddy
one of my best friends again in cow head
in Tampa and his co-host Galvin one of
the things that when I first met him
that we connected almost mega-money
because I just met Tosh I think I just
met Tosh who introduced me to Eddie and
there they made me not accept a date for
sure Oh hundred percent we had an
interesting he's the only employee that
he doesn't yell at it I've never I've
never even been over there I've had me
open for Daniel's sometimes and then on
the show I had me like try and kickflip
on a moving treadmill and I like cracked
foot rib I think so that would I still
get checks I got a check for seventy
cents the other day is the residual how
did you be taught from at cap city yeah
Brendan and I were doing this sketch
show and at the tail end of it that was
a Tosh week at cap city and before he
was famous or anything but we would we
do all these sketches and we were doing
a live show with like Mears we were
singing and breakdancing it was a rig
was called the hyper Jackson Chamber the
most obnoxious name for a thing but but
that's how I met him and he's like how
did you guys do this it's funny every I
remember him being what impressed with
something we were doing and I'm just
kind of still in the same place
he's I he blew me away oh yeah this is
one of the guys that he's the opposite
of what we said and he's maybe I don't
know if he's an exception of the rule or
whatever but like he is a somewhat of a
hard-working guy yeah but he is he does
have a lazy man's brain I think you know
like surfing and meditation and yeah man
that's what I relate to the first time I
saw him do stand-up I thought okay this
there's a cheat code involved that's too
good yeah I'm ever thinking I remember
thinking he supposed to be stealing
these jokes from someone no one's that
fun he's never not in control - yeah and
he was so confident and me and Gary
Goldman went I visit Gary Gulman it was
such an integral part
my life for such a long time right when
I had kids that didn't feel like I had
an outlet or anyone to talk to him and
Steve Burns Steve Byrne was so [ __ ]
good to me man yeah he burned pulled me
aside one time I was like hey man you
need some friends and I was like I was
like obvious before you did like the
whiskey tour with him didn't ya before
this because you need some friends like
let me introduce you to some people and
I introduced me to all my friends yeah
I've never had anyone do that in my life
even in third grade he was [ __ ] great
I and and but can you tell me something
we could just like during his special
ways like here's my brother and then it
just a version of him stands up wearing
military and they sits down does he this
as brother is he hilarious okay there
because I when I did my premium blend I
was like I had to go back because DL
Hughley was drunk or something and said
my name wrong but I still went out and
did myself a Fairchild Spanx I don't
know he was like Chris they're something
and someone got on the screen very fair
week he's week right when I went up so I
had to go back the next day and reshoot
just walking to the mic and grabbing the
mic so I throwed my hair out and my
watch I put on a different risk so you
real closely you can see my watch goes
in my hair go through like but while we
were just shooting that real quick they
put some people in front just crew
people to be the backs of heads and I
was like can I please sit up front and
can you take a shot of me laughing
wearing the same thing just laughing at
myself but I thought that would be so
funny especially back then on people do
weird audience stuff now but I thought
at the time just in a packaged edited
premium blend one of the comics has
himself laughing at him just a real
quick and they were like that's funny
let's do it but I think that buckles or
whoever it was came in and said no we're
not going to hold a mirror up to the
fact that we edit this show like that so
I didn't but anyway yeah anyway got Neha
sure sure we um me and Gary when I'm
wearing Megan Muniz blouse on my premium
blend by the way I just read exceeding
suggest I am NOT I'm not kidding you
serious
a bullet seemingly a black button-up
shirt but I had shoulder pads and I just
pulled them out there's like velcro
shoulders a woman's shirt I look great
in it it looks nice I look nice in that
shirt if you go watch my premium LED
wearing a nice black shirt because I
didn't bring anything what a dummy I
gotta fly to New York no I had like a
dirty shirt I wore all my clothes and
then I guess I got fish guts cuz I was
jumping in the trash the garbage people
are on strike anyway all my clothes were
dirty and and I got I'm wearing Megan's
shirt anyway okay so yeah I guess you
couldn't borrow Eddie no no no I know I
did what but I
that was a cape that I took off right
when I got on stage take of this uh-oh
all see
so Daniel taught the truck at this
pointless the point is that Gary and I
found out that he was touring non-stop
yeah they're blown away we couldn't even
figure out a feature right and you
couldn't figure out how to get on the
road like none of that made sense it
wasn't like the internet wasn't around
for you to be able to use the whip a
hand now and build a riot or whatever
you got to sit and wait your turn
well if I'm not mistaken in your florida
guy originally right didn't he have he
had a show where he'd like rape women or
some yeah it's like if you hear about
now it's like that would not fly hey
you're about Nate like I never watched
it but he was well-known in Florida from
that so he just I think he skipped the
whole featuring for people process and
just said hey Miami improv still how do
you get that funny without right I look
how do you get that funny without living
in New York and Ella
he just right away was they began
immediately yeah just leapfrogged into
like really great writing confidence
that I still after eighteen seventeen
years heaven I mean he immediately had
that he leaped he kicked we worked
together in in Miami one weekend the the
week after Georgia was born not the week
she was born I wanted to tell the very
next I flew home on Monday on Monday
flew back on Thursday worked with Tosh
that weekend and I remember being like I
remember he kicked a dude out in the
front row
before he got on stage like he walked on
stage said you're leaving right now oh
there's a packed room and I was like why
I got off stage
this guy was heckling and I just type
and you say at a mountain dew football
jersey or something and that's a that
makes sense yeah oh dude he [ __ ]
kicked him out and he's like kicking out
you and your mullet get the [ __ ] out
[ __ ] your nights over shows done
doesn't start until this [ __ ]
gentleman leaves kicking the [ __ ] out
like we really and the guy done nothing
know you've been heckling me okay and
and I just put up with it when I got off
his words to me by the way I don't think
we'd ever even met mmm I don't think he
is shy was it I'd gone on stage before
you even gotten in his word first words
to me were that's one way to do it and I
was like I was like well I didn't want
to [ __ ] up the show
yeah like you would not [ __ ] up the show
by kicking him out yeah we I didn't want
to kick someone I'm just featuring he
goes I don't give a [ __ ] someone's
ruining show you [ __ ] ask him to
leave and so he just walked out he's
like you're the [ __ ] out here go go and
the guy they kicked him out and tossed
got into like a shouting non shouting
cuz he didn't his energy didn't he
didn't let himself but it's man if they
[ __ ] shouting match the last words
toss says to him is by the way this is
2004 I hope you get aids [ __ ] crowds
like holy [ __ ] yeah and then he looks at
the crowd he goes the good kind of aids
like magic concen eighth-place turns
around he goes his next joke was Kobe
Bryant so good at basketball I believe
he should be allowed to rape women and
the [ __ ] place went nuts and they
loved him Nia is that's I and I see that
Jeselnik there's so many comics that
save stuff that's like if someone on
paper said someone white got on stage
and was able to get away with saying
that I'm like well then the audience is
paid or said I I can't believe what I
just know what I can't say on the stage
well weird it's weird whoa I think
that's changed Chappelle's special was
so subtly politically insensitive and I
don't mean not there's no slide on it
but it was enjoyable to see someone not
really give a [ __ ] what I said I've read
some negative stuff about some of the of
course people are going to do that now
paper there's social media warriors that
you literally
it was like it was almost like he's been
it and it like it was it was refreshing
to see that I guess you can't get in
trouble anymore yeah maybe I mean I bet
he's not gonna be in trouble [ __ ] all
over circle yeah and maybe that's Trump
maybe I don't know what it is it's nice
for me cuz I go there's a lot of things
I've wanted to say that I just go I
guess you can't really say that now I'm
not saying that anything can be said
about it's positive about Trump right
now it is yeah I guess we can all say as
long as it falls short of you know
grabbing a [ __ ] and or just the entire
race groups go home you know that hey
race group go home that's of classically
what you're not supposed to say anymore
so now we can I can joke about a gay guy
or something right my point was was I
just don't want to deal with the [ __ ]
headache and that was another thing I
talked about in therapy a lot of things
you know when I was on Travel Channel I
cried
in order like Patrice once said um
good joke or a bad joke come from the
exact same place mm the joke that you
protest comes from the exact same
birthplace as a joke you fall in love
with ray because it's just a chance you
don't know if it's gonna be funny you
can't know until you put it out to an
audience you can write a song and play
it for a friend
I can't run a joke by my friend who
might have the same [ __ ] up sense of
humor I do and then we go on from an
audience everyone's like what the [ __ ]
did he just say yeah and so um it for me
I find that really fascinating that like
watching Chappelle's special I mean I'm
not that I haven't heard anything
negative I'm guess it's out there but
like I mean yeah I've heard it's great
I'm you just online there's people that
and I guess there's job they make goes
on he does a rant about a gay blogger
and basically oh that Milo kinda the was
that who didn't he's a Breitbart
right-wing guy but he happens to also be
gay but he's kind of like it self-hating
but yeah I know who model is we all got
who the maybe that says this is when I
wish I had a Jamie
well go Jamie pull that up yeah yeah
just a mental rolodex of facts
I am NOT that person [ __ ] I love having
friends of gossip hey everyone real
quick oh this is not going to help go
check out Tom Rhodes - he just texted me
he's inside splatter sigh splitters this
weekend but that's last weekend so he
just missed it so check out lady mom
Rhodes is a big [ __ ] Houston guy yeah
he was always at the he was doing our
level Velveeta room way back then he was
living in like Amsterdam permanently he
was like an Amsterdam resident at that
time but yeah that guy traded hilarious
yeah he's great so he reminds me a match
sometimes he does there's a little hit I
think you know I think it was different
voice really you know yeah I guess Emily
really
he's more ranty but he's got a soul this
to his voice yeah yeah yeah he's like a
jazz singer it's so funny I think see if
you had a mic he could be picking up
this this audio yeah that's a siren song
this sucks if you have a new gardener
and he tore down our bird of paradise
because he's like you don't wanted some
fringing on your house so he turned it
down but then you can egging here
everything in the alley okay yeah
I didn't [ __ ] scare the [ __ ] out of
me and not have panic attacks I can hear
things like it sounds like they're
technically they are in your backyard
because there's just a fence so the
sound sounds like they're directly in
your backyard
okay so it freaks me the [ __ ] out um do
you think you'll ever have kids I it
sweet something just happened to me
where I want to have kids it just have a
long ago we took uh and it I more or
less I mean I want have kids I'm not
saying I wanna get married with it I
mean yeah I kind of am in the same place
there where I haven't seen that work
I've seen having kids work out for
people but the marriage say I'm so
scared of not to come in that's a dude
commitment thing but I am so much easier
having it I can't I can't kids like me
it's weird but I try and talk about and
I just come off coming weird especially
when I have a mustache you can't just
say you like people's kids but I like
mine E&F your nieces it's okay for me
like them the people always you know
can't just talk to kids like in a mall
you know
go to group kids and be like hey I'm
kidding
please anyone that takes things
seriously I'm a sarcastic person sorry
we work together when we can embrace
your candies of redhead yeah Hanukkah no
that doesn't that's dumb i but yeah I do
I think I'd be good at I used to work at
a daycare before I moved to Texas did
that was the last thing I did I worked
at a daycare and it was so fun just it
really is how I got my exercise and put
kids on my shoulders and run around this
back play yard area and that's all they
wanted they're like run me around on
your shoulders I'm like all right I'm
trying to get in shape and that was fun
though some of those kids are in their
20s now it's so funny with you yeah
Montana it was a my oats my friend we
lived next to it my friend's mom ran
this daycare so what was uh what was
what was Montana like it's great I just
got back a day before yesterday do you
have any Montana in you like meaning
like yeah I think so I mean I'm from
Florida so like I'll tell you that what
I mean by that question I'm from Florida
I still like to smoke weed in the day
and drink a cold cup of cold beers like
every now and then I like to go off the
rails and then sometimes I like to
really get down and hunker down like if
I go if it's a Saturday or on vacation
I'm old school like my friends boom I
want to drink all day right like that's
Florida mentality is like Florida
mentality also is is very rude to turn
down drugs like that's all my friends
grew up can I tell you what happened to
me in Florida because of the pressure to
do drugs and this is what going back to
why I got called by the bank at your
house and they said someone tried to
spend ten thousand dollars I have a
Nordstrom in Hollywood where that improv
is has opened him for Greg Behrendt and
I did very poorly and the audience
didn't like me but there's these ladies
after the show that were like fun moms
with with Jimmy Buffett shirts and they
bought me all these fruity drinks and I
was getting drunk with these ladies they
were like you were gay just didn't get
you we thought you were terrific and
there's one dude with them who looked
like a he just looked like a bro a dude
but he had a crazy shirt and weird
patent
leather loafers he was like kind of a
weird dude and he wasn't talking much
but then these ladies it got all pulp
fiction II because they were like all of
a sudden they all got up and said we
have to go we have to pick up our
daughters we're at a dance club do you
want keep hanging out and I'm like all
these ladies have daughters and the guy
was like they're they're hot dude he was
like I'm like great sure I have a room
here
go get the daughters and come back all
of you and the guys like well I'll just
hang out with you and so we went up to
my room and he had coca now in July
drugs but sometimes it's rude to turn
down coke and Florida
I just mean shirt it's rude it's rude
coke important really is and yeah and so
this guy went up and we did some coke
like on the ironing board and and I was
didn't even get the chance to know him I
woke I woke up and eyes on the floor and
I was leaning against a chair like my
head like I'd fallen like that and this
guy was across the room and he was
masturbating he didn't have his pants
down by his hand and his pants and he
was jerking off or pretending to at
first I woke up and I'm like huh
like and I said can you please stop
doing eyes real scared couldn't feel my
legs and and he said he was kept saying
I'm not gay I'm not gay you never he's
like you never in a frat hung out and
did this with your friends and he's
masturbating this whole time and I'm
like no and gay it's not really the
issue I just would love it if you'd stop
it's making me feel uncomfortable and I
feel like maybe I've been drugged and I
was real scared and and I finally got
him to slow down the story you are you I
want to get through but you do wanna
cook and then you then you just that's
what I'll never know these ladies were
the ones given me drinks for the longest
time I thought they were like in a
that's why I've said pulp fiction it
seemed like a hey we got one for you bub
like like the guy chained up to get
raped in the basement and the guys the
store guys and the guy comes over how
old are you in the story uh this was
right when right before we started
reality bites back really and then and
then some credit card fraud capsule
cubes okay so so I had my pants on but
maybe grab my wallet I don't know
sweet so your wake up guys jacking off
you're like stop a and it was like four
in the morning I mean what you're saying
is a hate crime yeah or that's honestly
people always like why didn't you get
first I couldn't get up but they're like
why didn't you beat him up or you and
I'm like it really felt like I
immediately felt bad for someone that is
has to do this you know or it gets
turned on by this or you know people
like Cosby who like need get a boner
from asleep people you're [ __ ] up yet
on that I had been I I don't fall asleep
that easily and it was coke you know
it's like should be yeah I knew I'd been
drugged and I finally talked them into
just doing it in the bathroom and then
it's this is the jokey funny part but
it's true it's I realized I was going to
miss my flight and and I was like can
you when you're done in there can you
please give me a ride to the airport the
good he's like yeah totally and he did
about through masturbating and I'm like
trying to pack my bag your body starts
working yeah I could kind of crawl
around I'd like once I was like okay I I
just knew that when I woke up I'm like
there's a reason I'm like this but I
could wiggle undone I wasn't like bad in
the body your paw you're out of it I
would lean out of it for hours and I was
felt I don't know I tied up the next day
I felt like a weird hangover roofied I
don't know what I'd it's the only time
this is effing to me I don't know what
to compare it to but it was absolutely
horrifying and then and then at some
point he got I think it was like the cab
drivers used to do that carbon swipe and
had your full card number on it yeah I
remember getting on the plane like oh no
I hope that guy didn't pick up that card
and then when we were all at your house
with your kids I got a call from Wells
Fargo and they're like dude were you
just in Florida and I was like I want to
talk about it
like what do you what do you know so the
joke part is maybe wasn't masturbating
maybe in his pants he was just rubbing
my credit card with a crayon that's not
but I know he was actually masturbating
and it was [ __ ] horrifying and I kept
it to myself of course back then I've
talked I told that story on Road stories
at Murray's Road stories podcast but it
was a secret I kept for a long because
it felt do off also people don't have a
lot of sympathy when you get drugged
through your nose you know it's not like
I you know I thought for a long time you
put it right MA yeah yeah I put it in
this coke and I snorted it I'm a victim
no one really is on your side because I
don't know if it was those ladies but
they never came back
I mean they just left this weird guy
with me they were a weird group already
it's just so Florida suddenly to meet
this weird group of lady that is that
club has a bad rap you know what
happened to Mike uh Mike Young there at
the Hollywood it's in the Hard Rock yeah
yeah he got knocked out No
Oh Mike Young he was on my podcast he
told a little bit of the story so the
story him Brenner us I think Sebastian
Maniscalco all doing it they used to do
this young American colony tour I only
do it - we all used to do Steve burn
butch Bradley and they go they do the
show they go across the street across
the hall - are you going I have to go to
talk to Al about something that we're
doing it that big compound we went to
but do you have a one-inch so I did its
I didn't mean okay no we will write this
up okay cool
by the way I got to have you back this
has been the most seamless podcast like
literally it's like an hour 34 and I was
like oh I could do to another hour and a
half of them oh I live in [ __ ] ass
no this has been really fun yeah oh he
went over and he was just talking to a
girl and typical floor to move guy's
girlfriend and he just sucker punches
him and break like just punches him
breaks his orbital and whoa yeah I was
[ __ ] being the club in the end no in
the so they have like that you know the
wet willies where they buy all the fun
that place or right across I wasn't when
well he's talking at some girl and it
was going great we were even kissing and
stuff and then a dude came and grabbed
her and I was like what are you doing
he's like he was with her earlier and
left she's like I'm gonna hang out with
the comic he's like all right left
things were going great
he came back and it's my girlfriend I'm
like why didn't you say something
earlier but at least why don't you oh
yeah you don't have a promise ring it's
doing great or each other was my it's my
ex Emily all right
it's fine but I believe I yeah orbital
everyone there is might as well be an
MMA fighter though I you look around it
well you grew up for I mean in Florida
you know I would say that guns I got
guns pulled on me all the time
really yeah yeah I remember someone
telling me they were like so brusque I
was like I remember that I had the most
American thing happen to me I had a gun
pulled on you know like we don't tell
that story
yes I'm nine of them I mean I don't know
wow you cut off someone traffic and they
just pulled a gun that was very legal
you got ever gun in your car
Wow get a bit one step away from it so
you had to go reach for it and more
intelligence out you think in Texas it's
like a gun probably as much yes although
this sounds really silly but I think
Texas has more of a respect for guns in
Florida a right and I think in Florida I
remember being in a truck in the back of
my buddy cowhides truck and I just
bumped up to one of his guns and I took
it out sort of playing with it and every
one of my my friends at warm from
Florida were like what are you doing I
was like this is like just like it was a
time for Florida standing it I'm sorry
you're supposed to do tricks right away
right here yeah you put weight on this
ending a sucka to the Sun let's listen
to pit bull now but I think in Florida
there is there is an irresponsible miss
having a gun by the way look I'm your
kin so if you're from Florida you're
upset you have to agree there are just
times when people pull guns we have a
coffin traffic you're like dude it
doesn't need to be this however I
appreciate it I'll next time I'll pay
more attention when I cover I got a gun
pulled on me I had a boat I was towing
my boat and I forgot I had the boat on
and I just got over lanes and I pushed a
car into the next lane of traffic oh wow
and the guy came pulled up with a gun
out the window and I [ __ ] locked him
up and I had a boat on the back I just
and I was like he was gonna [ __ ]
shoot me
well like I remember I was in college
and we used to take our boat down the
st. Pete from Tampa and so you had to
drive it as a flat's boat they have good
flats down there and catch redfish or
maybe bone every now and then not really
bone but let's be honest though and so
but I remember a guy pulled a gun and I
was like oh he's gonna [ __ ] shoot me
that's how scared so funny in here I
remember what happened and you just
nothing he I locked him up everyone
locked up the guy kept going and then as
he tried to slow down there were several
cars already up behind him it was like
[ __ ] get off in the next exit [ __ ]
breathe I remember there's a lot by the
way that is a floor to move I hope to
god I'm not the only one experiences gum
pulled on you you get off immediately
and then you pull into like a Ramada Inn
parking lot in the back and you breathe
and pray that guy doesn't pull up next
to you right okay all right I gotta get
home yeah I get home time time to drive
down Florida Avenue or Nebraska and yeah
that's horrifying yeah that would have
never had a gun pulled on me sure had
people show me a gun in their pants oh
no no I had I've had I'm not joking I
probably had no lie probably eight guns
pulled on me in traffic all traffic wow
really yeah
all in traffic you know by the way this
is the eight guns from the period of 16
to 25 so in ten years
I don't either it would be bad but I'd
rhyme an idiot drive around with brass
knuckles and my dad gave me like a billy
club like brass knuckles
yeah I don't come soon punch someone in
the face with it if I have to I just
have them but it's less intimidating
when I just hold those and hope pray
you're laughing too hard I'm kind I'm a
bit of a discovery they are they are we
going to rumble they are perfect
everything in my car that I have to
defend myself is a silhouetted on a tsa
sign I've read
chuckles I have a round bomb with a whip
in my car
ah hey stars for I have the throwing
ninja star never Relling many stars be
dope I'll tell you what I got it which
is really great I'm always afraid
someone's gonna break into my house I
was in Africa with my buddy and we were
at this like resort but it was still
sketchy and I think we're in Zanzibar
Tanzania and my buddy had this headlamp
that was [ __ ] blinding was so big and
had an external battery to it meaning
like it had like a power pack sure it
just wasn't a battery that goes in the
front it had another power pack in the
back that made it heavy and these two
African dudes that were sketchy as [ __ ]
and not on the resort cut the corner and
my buddy flipped on his headlamp and
looked at them and it blinded them oh
well I bought this Phoenix flashlight
that is so it I think it's like 900
lumen um's
in the highest you can get however and I
just I carry it with me
there's someone in my back yard or if
someone broke into my house I hit them
with that and at least I can see them
and I can hit them and they'll be
[ __ ] blinded when I was young my mom
gave me pepper spray because I'm in
Montana and I'm skateboarding when used
to get in fights all the time because it
wasn't popular and my mom gave me pepper
spray early on and I've used it and it
works great really everyone should have
pepper spray if you're not a gun person
it will put it unless someone's on PCP
if you they're easy to use it's a steady
spray I give it as gifts can I also a
per trade works great I have a gun
my will rephrase that my wife has a gun
huh I have a pepper spray that looks
like a gun that's kind of funny that is
pulled out be happy this isn't a real
gun spray by the way it doesn't work on
people fill out and to like scare a
homeless guy out of my front yard who
was trying to get into my house here
yeah and he was like I don't care what
the gun or pepper spray I'm still
getting in there I don't care if your
dog and your kids are there
my kids are in the front yard this guy's
trying to get in to our front yard over
this fence okay scram I know do that you
see my dog hundred pounds
[ __ ] losing her minded this guy and
the guys just like he said he didn't
care just didn't give a [ __ ] and then
Priscilla I think was the reason he
backed off but I had this [ __ ]
handgun look like a handgun and he I
think he was like I am so done with his
life if it needs to go out this way let
it go now that's how where people are
hard to scare off yeah I've had it twice
we had what we did renovation on the
house two homeless people try to break
in a bullet it just keep happening there
it was woke because we had a porta potti
in her front yard so that was a public
restroom for them uh all aggregate
actually here in the middle of the night
so man's a [ __ ] nightmare head scan I
gotta get you out of here I'm going to I
will talk I will not stop talking to you
it's okay yeah yeah me too we'll just do
it again
we got an entire one yes let's do one
who could we do this is going to be a
big podcast but what I'll tell you right
now what gets huge ones for me is when
two people who would you like to do a
podcast with on this show like me you
can I invite one more comic makes me
laugh and he's really great on podcast
my friend you know Patrick Keane and all
adult the [ __ ] was very funny let's
do it let's do it Henry Phillips my
buddy Henry oh great Henry and if you
you know because you know maybe with him
but it's we have we can we know each
other where we have a lot of stories
where so yeah I was there let me tell
what really happened or you know things
look so what's all the let's set up a
boat okay cool that's cool okay great
are you still drinking yeah I'm afraid
so yeah baby all day one of them let's
do let's set I'll call I'll check Simon
Henry right now okay I will set up one
where the three of us have cocktails
okay cool but we'll do it maybe we'll go
meet at the bar over there I will do it
the man cave let's just do in the man
cave to share share more easy to manage
yeah I'll get I'll get some drinks for
all of us and we'll throw a party and
we'll have some cocktails it'll be a
[ __ ] blah and talk to Henry about his
new movie any yeah I just have all the
podcast
oh and by the way Henry makes me laugh
so [ __ ] hard yes he is so [ __ ]
funny he's got so many stories and he
doesn't forget a detail and that's what
that movie is basically it's just a list
of my texts okay call me right now not
as well a promote oh by the way by the
way all forests are finished I've got it
I'm gonna say
you and Leanne talk I want I want you to
do it to a poster for me okay yeah I
wouldn't yeah yeah I would love that
course yeah
I would love that I'll pay whatever
you're charged I'm on raise him of that
yeah cool I love that because I saw that
[ __ ] in and by the way if you're a comic
business hit up Chris Fairbanks this
poster he has of that I saw of Dana
Gould it bothered that was the one that
made me go to [ __ ] my like Dana Gould
has opposed her nothing against his old
it's just he doesn't seem like a guy who
gives a [ __ ] about making tour post
cutouts he's way in new a a he's kind of
I was like I was like he doesn't look
like you'd know funny thing is I don't
do this [ __ ] for myself I would never
make myself a poster oh do I love your
art so what are you going to wear can
people hit you up they want you to do a
tour poster Chris Fairbanks calm and
there your emails on there yeah yeah
there's no what's your Twitter contact
form Chris Fairbanks just crisp
everybody asked Chris are the same your
Instagram
doing everything right I don't know why
this isn't working out I just put all
the fun out fun Megan Moody's Twitter is
Z Megan Mooney is it when's the last
time she waited Emmy GaN mo o n ey she
tweeted one day ago okay I'm going to
see if I can find Eddie Gosling Eddie
goslings EBD IE g OS SL ing and Robert
Hawkins is the Hawks Nest I think comm
they used to be I don't know yeah
and so dude this was a [ __ ] blah yeah
yeah it was really fun take it away I'm
texting you and Henry right now okay
cool Thank You Man okay
[Music]
you
this episode was brought to you by the
machine
you